[Music]
good evening I'm Bret Baier tonight
President Trump is enduring some fears
Monday morning quarterbacking from NFL
players and others over calling an
audible about a visit a White House
visit from the Super Bowl champion
Philadelphia Eagles only a handful of
players were planning to attend the
president tied the incident to the
uproar over players protesting during
the national anthem but there are
problems with that line of reasoning
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts starts us off tonight from the
North Lawn of the White House jump
bracket evening to you it's no question
that President Trump has been in a
long-running feud with the NFL over
players kneeling or as the president
says disrespecting the national anthem
today that feud erupted into an all-out
war with the Philadelphia Eagles we love
our country we respect our flag and we
always proudly stand for the national
anthem we always will stand for the
national anthem President Trump didn't
even mention the Philadelphia Eagles on
the South Lawn today an event that was
originally to celebrate their Super Bowl
victory turned into a celebration of the
military the flag and American
patriotism we stand to honor our
military and to honor our country and to
remember the fallen heroes who never
made it back home we stand to show our
love for our fellow citizens and our
magnificent Constitution the president
canceled the Eagles celebration last
night after the team said only two or
three players owner Jeffrey Lurie and
swoop the Eagles mascot would attend
there were 80 members of the Eagles
organization that RSVP'd and committed
to attend this event as recently as
Friday as well as over a thousand fans
of the Eagles organization and the
Eagles are the ones that tried to change
their commitment at the 11th hour
Philadelphia Mayor Jim Kenney didn't
hold back one bit in a statement saying
disinviting them from the white house
only proves that our president is not a
true patriot but a fragile egomaniac
obsessed with crowd size and afraid of
the embarrassment of throwing a party to
which no one wants
to attend the White House insists the
Eagles were playing politics suggesting
the White House visit be moved to next
week when they knew the president would
be in Singapore to meet Kim jong-un look
if this wasn't a political stunt by the
Eagles franchise then they wouldn't have
planned to attend the event and then
backed out at the last minute and if it
wasn't a political stunt and they
wouldn't have attempted to reschedule
the visit when they knew that the
president was going to be overseas
president Trump blamed the players for
the fiasco in a statement saying they
disagree with their president because he
insists that they proudly stand for the
national anthem hand on heart in honor
of the great men and women of our
military and the people of our country
but former Eagles wide receiver Torrey
Smith was quick to remind on Twitter no
one on the Eagles took a knee last
season President Clinton's former press
secretary Joe Lockhart who was also the
NFL's communications director said the
president is out of bounds on this one I
think it's the latest example of the
imperial presidency how Trump sees
himself as a president last time I
checked it wasn't his house he doesn't
get to decide you know people this is
the people's house and it shouldn't
matter whether ten players are coming or
thirty players are coming the president
Trump will likely face another sports
boycott later on this year both LeBron
James and Steph Curry have said that
neither the Cleveland Cavaliers nor the
Golden State Warriors would come to the
White House depending on who wins the
NBA championships that are currently
underway last year the Golden State
Warriors were about to decline an
invitation to the White House President
Trump got wind of it and jumped out
ahead of them disinviting them but the
feud continuing to go on between the
president the NFL and the NBA Brett and
John a new development regarding Kelly
Sadler at the center of that controversy
about the comments about Senator John
McCain Kelly Sadler was that she is the
they was at least the head of surrogate
communications here at the White House
got into a controversy in a meeting she
said about John McCain while he's dying
anyways the White House refused to
apologize Kelly Sadler refused to
apologize in the wake of that we are
told tonight by senior administration
officials that Kelly Sadler is
no longer with the Whitehouse Brett
interesting John Roberts live in the
North Lawn John thanks well what do you
think do you think the president made
the right call about the Philadelphia
Eagles drop me a line on Twitter at Bret
Baier you can use the hashtag special
report or on Facebook at facebook.com
slash Bret Baier
Sr